Hi, I'm Lisa Manning. I'm an assistant
professor at Syracuse University.
So we've been interested in trying to
understand how groups of cells interact
with one another mechanically to
generate properties of biological
tissues and processes like development.
This is really important because it
turns out that lots of cells have
signaling molecules that can measure
things about their mechanical
environment and respond to it and that's
one way of programming interesting
patterns during development. And in
particular we've been interested in
understanding whether groups of cells
behave more like a fluid or more like a
solid and it turns out that the tools of
Glassy physics of glassy material
science help us to understand how groups
of disordered things whether they be
atoms or they be cells can transition
from a fluid like behavior to a solid
like behavior and so we've been thinking
about this problem and we've learned
that when groups of cells change single
cell properties things like the number
of caderents which is the adhesive
molecules that help cells stick together
or the expression levels of actin or
myosin which help give the cells
mechanical integrity they can actually
drive the entire tissue from a fluid to
a solid and those transitions can help
shape organs into functional structures
and they can help change the way the
tissue responds to mechanical forces and
so we think that this shows a lot of
promise for understanding how organs
change their shape during development,
with implications for congenital disease.